hello a very good morning to you
President Vladimir zielinski is calling
for the world to help with the dam
collapse in southern Ukraine which has
triggered a humanitarian and ecological
disaster Ukraine and Russia are accusing
each other of blowing up the dam in case
on which is occupied by Russian troops
well the first deaths from the flooding
were announced last night by a local
mayor who's been exiled since Russia
seized the region in one area of the
city there are suggestions the water
level has risen above five meters
it's still unclear if Russia is to blame
for the destruction but Kiev has called
the breach a war crime in his nightly
addressed president zielinski called on
the world for help
absolutely
the situation in the occupied part of
the herzan region is absolutely
catastrophic the Occupy is simply
abandoned people in these terrible
conditions without rescue without water
just on roofs of houses in flooded
communities and this is another
deliberate crime of Russia after the
terrorist state has caused a catastrophe
it also maximizes the damage from it
what is needed now is a clear and Swift
response from the world to what is
happening
well Skye's special correspondent Alex
Crawford joins me now from cairson and
Alex just how big a disaster is this for
Ukraine describe to us what you've seen
there in case on
I think it's an enormous disaster it's a
humanitarian and environmental
catastrophe and crisis even if there is
any dispute about who did this it is a
huge potential War crime basically
playing out in real time in front of us
these people have lived under bombing
shelling artillery and they still are
it's a constant drum roll in the
background throughout the day and now
they've got flooding massive flooding
over a huge area which is going to turn
not just environmental agricultural land
into they say deserts it's leaving
sewage debris oil there are floating
land mines here as well
creating all sorts of Hazards and of
course there is the immediate immediate
humanitarian and animal cost rescuing
humans who are stranded and rescuing
animals who are dying let me just bring
in Niels who's a professional
firefighter from Germany who's one of
the very very few foreigners who are
here helping in anything because what
struck me is that it's mostly ukrainians
and not very many large numbers of
ukrainians large numbers of smaller
numbers of Ukrainian volunteers some
professionals military and police but
it's quite a small scale rescue effort
in in comparison to the huge catastrophe
what are you planning to do or hoping to
do today
so I'm hoping that we can rescue many
people I don't know the exact numbers at
the moment you're waiting for
coordinations where we have to go next
we already rescued a couple of people it
was the rescued animals and I'll be
waiting for them for their coordination
as a as a professional firefighter I
mean how how
experienced are you in dealing with
these sort of conditions and how would
you describe them
I mean like I mean like this is this is
the goodest trophy what is
it a huge area actually so this scale
yeah so you've never seen anything quite
this big and what about have you been
able to work out the conditions that
you're going to have to be plunging
yourself itself in for in terms of
because they're talking about disease
and possibly an outbreak of Cholera
there's lots of sewage you can see it
floating around
this is actually what comes afterwards
at the moment we just have we just have
the evocation okay and how are you going
to do that how are you going to try
you've got you've brought you've brought
equipment
professional we have we have a bit
equipment it's not enough we need more
boats like I see it we need also more
live jackets and other equipment for
water rescuing and
it's I actually don't know how many
people are out there so we just wait
okay well good luck today Niels and
thanks for talking to us good luck
um as you can see they're a very very
few foreign relief workers and emergency
aid workers who are here on the ground
right at the epicenter if you like of
the flooding and I think there's a
growing need and concern that the world
just isn't listening and helping right
now